- Welcome back, y'all.
My next guest is one of the hottest names
in country music right now.
He's got six platinum hits
and his latest single is
called "Lady," nicely done.
Please say hello to Brett Young everybody.
(upbeat music)
Hello.
Oh, I like your art
- Thank you.
- Your art, yeah.
- Thank you, I had nothing to do with it.
- Oh, well you did, it's on you.
- That's true, that's true.
I was the canvas, I guess.
- I didn't realize how
freaking tall you are.
- I know, it's, my wife
is 5'3" so it's a strange.
- Oh my god, I'm 5'", that's why you...
- [Brett] You are?
- Yeah, I was like, Oh
my gosh, you're tall.
- She, we had to go through
this whole conversation
early in the relationship
where she was like,
stop bending down for the photo.
Stand up, it's okay that you're tall.
- Yeah, except I always
have this conversation
with my other short friends that date
or married, tall, tall men.
Like, it's gotta be awkward, you know?
'Cause you're kissing,
like when you're standing,
it's just, are you always hunched over?
- Yeah, unless you want
to do that whole like,
"50 Shades of Gray," thing
where you pick her up.
- Well, some of us can't
be picked up, Brett.
- Stop.
- Some of us, I'm like, hey, look,
I'll climb on this stairs.
- We have like, baby
number two on the way.
- [Kelly] Congratulations.
- Thank you, can or can't is
not really a thing anymore.
It's just like, that's not the stage
in the relationship right now.
We're not flinging each
other around the house.
- So wait, do you know
if it's a boy or girl?
- Actually we do and we
thought it would be a fun way
to announce that.
- On here?
- Do the reveal right
here, today with you.
- Let's do it.
- Yeah, I think we have,
since my wife and my
baby couldn't be here,
I thought it would be fun
to at least use a picture.
So I don't know if you
guys can tell that there
aren't any blue balls
in the tub with Presley.
But we've got baby girl
number two on the way.
- That is exciting.
- Yeah, so I need to get
boy dogs or something.
I know that's what, yeah.
I was gonna say.
- Isn't she cute, look at her.
- She's adorable.
- She's just learning
how to take care of her,
her little baby dolls.
So maybe in July, when,
when her sister comes
she'll be ready, but yeah, baby,
baby girl Young number two.
- Are you gonna keep trying for a boy?
- Oh, I don't know.
- I mean, I guess you're
not doing any of it.
Is she gonna to keep trying?
- I think for me, it's just the fun part.
So if, if she gets through this labor,
the first labor was actually pretty rough.
- Oh, mine too.
- So, you know, you
gotta like wrap your head
around the idea of another
and now she's having another.
So I think if it's rough
again, she's probably done.
If it's easier than the first one, maybe.
- Man, they kept telling me my second one,
they were like, oh, no way it's gonna be
like your first one.
I was hospitalized, it was horrible.
And then it was worse and I was like, wow,
you can go ahead and remove those tubes.
I was like...
- Fully done with these.
- Yeah, I don't need any of these anymore.
It was bad.
But wait, I find this interesting
because you're gonna be 40 soon, right?
- Yeah, so I turned 40.
Yeah, this month.
- This month?
- Yeah.
- Oh, are you an Aries?
- I am.
- Okay, I'm a Taurus.
I'm about to be 39.
I'm a year behind you.
But I think it's awesome 'cause
you're doing this challenge,
which I don't know why.
Cause you're really thin, so whatever,
but you're like a guy that's
like, I need to lose weight.
And then you like stopped drinking Cokes
and you're like, lose 40 pounds.
It's amazing.
And I'm like, I mean, it's
really great for y'all.
But anyway, my point is,
is you're doing this thing
to be, it's like you're Fit 40 Challenge,
is that what it is?
- Yeah, we're calling
it the BY 40 Challenge.
So basically what I,
when the baby was born.
- Oh, so bye 40 challenge, okay, cool.
- Yeah, so if the baby had been born
and then COVID didn't happen,
I probably would have taken
like a month or two off from exercising
to like, be present.
But then right at the end
of that first couple of months, COVID hit
and the next thing I knew it was 14 months
that I hadn't gone back to
the gym, back to baseball,
something that had been a part
of my life for my whole life.
It was just part of the routine.
And then you get into music
and that's part of it,
you know, the aesthetics of everything.
And I was 14 months and
25 pounds up and I went,
you know what?
Accountability is the
only thing that's going to
make me stick to this thing.
And so I went out and got
in touch with a trainer
who trains like, superheroes.
He trained Ryan Reynolds,
Hugh Jackman, John Krasinski
like he's, he's, that's what he does.
- Are those workouts from hell?
- They're, you know what?
He's awesome.
He, yes, they suck.
- Oh.
- But he makes it compatible.
But he did my workout for
me based on my gym at home.
And then did a version of
that with just dumbbells
for everybody that's joining
to just do it at home.
- Oh, 'cause you're doing it with fans.
- Yeah, so we, we, we
created this challenge where
like, people can complete a task
and earn points and we have great partners
and Don and myself did
like, meet and greets
and show tickets and stuff like that
as prizes that you can win by
competing in the challenge.
And so there are, the first
day I think there were
like, over 1000 signups
in the first 24 hours.
And I noticed it's like, spread
out all over the country.
So people are posting videos.
- I think a lot of people have
probably been in your shoes.
Like, you know what I'm saying?
Especially people that don't
have gyms in their home
and they used to go to the
gym, like the whole pandemic,
I think everybody's been like that.
- Right, you can't go
to the gym and whiskey
becomes your best friend,
all at the same time.
You're like, this is not good.
So yeah, I just wanted
to A, put it out there
so I would be held accountable.
And I'm down at this
point, I'm almost done
with the challenge and I'm
down, I gained 25 pounds.
I'm down 21.
- Dang.
- So I'm almost back.
- That's so great.
- But also the, the people that are well,
the, Don calls me everyday and yells at me
if I'm not doing it, so...
- See, I just wouldn't
answer my phone, Brett.
- Just put it on silent, yeah.
- And, decline.
- No, he's the best, he's like, he's not,
he's not the guy that's
like, you're screwing up.
He's like, he's the you can do this guy.
And then if you complain,
he's like, eh, you'll be fine.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I know I
have to have that person
or I don't do it, obviously.
I have a gym in my house and it's pretty.